[Music]
hi everyone i'm jeevana hikdi a customer
engineer at google cloud
and welcome back to the technical guide
for startups where we are helping
startups for technical enablement to
start build and grow their businesses
successfully and sustainably on google
cloud
in our previous video we introduced you
to the series and now we're on to the
second episode which is all about
getting started on google cloud
in this video we are going to be
covering how to create a google cloud
account so you get started on the google
cloud platform get a brief overview of
the resource hierarchy
understand why an organization is
important and how to create one how to
create a folder how to create a project
and do an entire run through of the
google cloud console so we get the
fundamentals in place and finally we
will be going over identity and access
management for building your security
fundamentals and wrap up with some
actionable next steps so without any
further ado let's get on to exploring
the google cloud platform together
before jumping onto the demonstration
there's something you need to keep in
mind
once you create your account you
actually need to activate it in order to
use it and for this you'll be required
to put in your payment details
by default you're provided with 300 of
credits and this is more than sufficient
in case you're just planning to
experiment
or practice for a certification
once those credits are over you will
have to manually upgrade to a payment
year to continue working so don't worry
as you are not auto charged once your
trial expires
but in any case it's always good to know
that you have to deallocate delete and
stop the resources that you do not
require now let's go with the absolute
fundamental step which is creating your
google cloud account
to start off i've opened an incognito
window which makes it convenient in case
you're working with different accounts
and then open up the
console.cloud.google.com
now we either create a new account or we
can simply sign into an existing one if
you have it just put in your credentials
and log in
now here let's go over how to create a
new one
click on create account and choose for
myself or my business but know that the
steps are pretty much the same in any
case
fill in the details like the name email
address create a new one if you have to
and also set a strong password
once you're done click on next
you're then asked to fill in a phone
number and a verification code is sent
to it so put in this code when prompted
once you have all of that verified your
google cloud platform opens up but with
a pop-up
all you have left to do is select your
country now and agree to the terms of
service
click on the check box and click on
agree and continue
congratulations now you have yourself
your google cloud account
but like i already mentioned you now
need to activate it so let's go ahead
and do that
this is a three-step method
select your country and tell us what
describes your organization the best i
probably go ahead here and say startup
and click on continue and when you do
you are asked to verify the phone number
that you wanted to be contacted in in
case of any support issues etc
and then go to the final step
and finally all you have to do is
confirm your account type fill in your
business name fill in your payment
method and your card details etc and
understand all the information in detail
and all you have to do is click on start
my free trial
now that we've began our journey by
creating an account let's go over
understanding what a resource hierarchy
on google cloud is
a resource hierarchy helps us understand
how your resources are going to be
organized which is extremely crucial
when your organization is scaling out
and is a great foundation to
understanding inheritance of access
control and organization policies for
your resources to the bottom most of the
hierarchy we have all our resources
which are essentially all the products
and services like your compute engine
instances machine learning apis
databases and everything else
this is where your application really
stands
resources can only be parented by
projects and this becomes the first
grouping mechanism in your google cloud
resource hierarchy
you need to have at least one project to
get started with building your resources
it is a best practice that you segregate
your projects based on your environment
such as development test and production
this way the flow is kept clean easy to
manage debug and scale
right about projects we have folders
these folders can contain other projects
as well as folders
this provides an additional grouping
mechanism to help keep your resources
and accesses restricted maybe department
wise team wise and so on
maybe you wouldn't want your research
team's resources to be accessed by the
other departments so you can keep them
isolated yet under one roof
and that one roof is an organization
this is the umbrella for your entire
company and acts as the root node it is
a prerequisite for you to have an
organization in order to use folders
now that we have a broader understanding
of the entire resource hierarchy let's
try and understand an organization in a
little more detail and why it's so
important
organizations provide central visibility
and control over every resource that
belongs to that organization
the im access control policies applied
to an organization applied throughout
the hierarchy to all the resources it is
not required or mandatory to have an
organization but some features of a
resource manager will not be usable
without one
if you are a google workspace or a cloud
identity user when you create a google
cloud project an organization is
automatically provisioned now without
any further ado let's jump onto the demo
i'm doing so by creating a cloud
identity account
the link to this is in the description
box below
now click on next put in your business
name and select the number of employees
present in your company i'm picking um
100 to 299 for the purpose of this demo
and then click on next
select your business location and
business phone number
moving on provide your current email
address i'm just going to go ahead and
type in a mock email address here
and then add in your business's domain
name address once you've added this
you're asked to verify it and confirm
just to be sure once you confirm it the
next step is to put in the account
administrator's full name
you can change who you give this role to
even once it's created so know that you
don't necessarily have to be the
permanent one in charge even though
you're creating it right now
anyway very quickly moving on to the
next step it's for you to pick a
username and a very strong password for
your cloud identity account and then
click on next
the last few steps would be for you to
choose whether or not you want to
educate your users regarding workspace
apps new features etc i'm just going to
say no thank you for now and move on
the final step is simply for you to
confirm that you're not a robot and then
click on agree and create account
congratulations now you have yourself a
cloud identity account which also means
you have an organization for you to get
started with
now that we have an organization we can
create a folder so let's go ahead and
try that
click here and you can see which
organization is open
now click on these three dots and select
manage resources
this takes you to where you can see a
hierarchy very clearly but remember you
need the right access controls in the
first place to be able to view all of
this and we'll come to that in just a
bit
now let's create our folder i'm going to
quickly give it a name let me call it
demo
dash startups dash juvenile so maybe all
my demos are going to be present under
this folder and now i can browse where i
want to be creating this folder let me
directly say this is going to be under
the organization and then click on
create now we just wait a couple of
seconds and when we have the refresh
notification pop up here we simply
refresh the screen
and that's it we have our folder here
now quickly from where we left off let's
create a project because otherwise you
can't really provision any resources
let's try to create this and see what
happens
click on create project to create a new
one as you can see it's already giving
me a name and a project id the project
id needs to be a globally unique one
and it's not necessary for the project
name and id to match but it's a best
practice to do so as it's just easier to
fetch in the future and the project id
cannot be changed once it's created
let me just try and type in a unique
name here maybe technical guide demos
so if i remove the demos from this you
can see it adds a new variables
automatically for the project id to make
it globally unique
but let's leave it at technical guide
demos and then browse the location where
you want to create this project
let's create this under the folder which
we had created earlier and then click on
create
oh wait a minute do we see an error here
well that was expected and that's
because i don't have the right
permissions yet to be able to create
this project
you need the resource manager project's
create permission to be able to do so
and this permission is included in the
project creator role so let's quickly
head on to iam and provision that
we'll see iam in a little more detail in
just a couple of minutes
when you come here you can already see
the permissions available for a couple
of users let's just try and add a new
role and provision it to myself
luckily i have the permission to give
myself the permission to be able to do
so if not someone else would have to do
it for me
anyway i'm selecting project creator
here and saving it
now you can see that i have the
permission that i need so let's just go
back and create the project
there are a bunch of ways where you can
go and land in the same creating the new
project page so maybe going here and
clicking on new project
or going back and doing what we did
before through the manage resources page
i'm just going to go ahead and give it
this name cross the location and now
click on create
this alarm bell here will give us a
notification when the project is ready
and notifications throughout
there shouldn't be any error now so
let's just wait
now let me quickly refresh the page and
expand the folder and here you go your
project has now been created it's that
easy
now that we have a project to work with
let's get a broad understanding of the
google cloud platform console
always important to keep in mind that
you need the required permissions to
access any resource via the console or
the command line interface
i'm selecting a project
and your landing page is your dashboard
the dashboard gives you an overview of
your project some project information
resources you probably have provisioned
monitoring details billing details etc
you can also customize what you see on
your dashboard by clicking on the
customize option
let's say i don't want the project
details and monitoring details to show
up so i'm just going to switch the
toggle buttons and click on done
and as you can see it's gone
the next basic feature is to the top
left corner here it opens up the
navigation menu it has all the products
and resources that you can provision and
for convenience it's segregated based on
different categories such as compute
serverless storage databases and more
an additional feature which comes in
handy is to pin the resources that you
use frequently you can further unpin it
by clicking on the same icon
another feature is if you're in another
product page all you have to do is click
on home to get back to your dashboard
click on this to view the organization
name you're working in
you have a list of recent projects
you're working on here
you can also start a couple of important
projects so let's say i start the other
project
and you can see them on the start tab
to view all the projects and folders
click on all you can further expand or
deflate them
now if i want to switch between two
projects all i have to do is select the
new project i want to work with
and it's really that simple to switch
the three dots on top here
will take you to these respective pages
and the new project as you've already
seen is to create a new project
right next to that we have the search
bar which is an easy way to find
anything on the google cloud platform
moving back this icon can be used to
activate your cloud shell terminal
this way you can type in your commands
instead of clicking your way through
resources
you can also click on open editor to get
a full page terminal
coming back clicking on this question
mark here will act as the help tool by
guiding you to a couple of resources
the bell icon like we discussed earlier
is to view your notifications
you can go through the project settings
and different utilities by clicking here
click on the extreme right top corner to
manage the account with which you're
logging in so you can add an account or
sign out here
for starters this should help the more
you work on the platform the more you
familiarize yourself with it so get
started without any delay
it's important to understand three
sections when we talk about identity and
access management or iems on google
cloud
the who
does what and earn what
the who is essentially the identity part
of the iams
the who talks about whether it's a
single user multiple users separately or
multiple users together
multiple users together is what is
referred to as a group and this is what
is recommended
the does what is the access or set of
access controls the user has on a
particular set of resource or so
for example something like an admin role
would allow you to create
modify delete add other roles etc
whereas a viewer role for a resource
would only allow you to read from it and
not modify or delete it
and finally we have the onward which
talks about which resource these
obligations are put on so let's say a
user has only been granted access to a
particular cloud sql database this does
not allow the user to access anything
apart from this particular cloud sql
database
here's an example to understand it as a
whole
there are a group of users who are
granted the access of cloud sql viewer
role and this grants them access to the
cloud sql
here are some best practices regarding
iems leverage and understand the
resource hierarchy use projects to group
resources that share the same trust
boundary
check the policy granted on each
resource and make sure you understand
the inheritance
use the principle of least privilege
which means don't over provision any of
the permissions that a user does not
require
grant roles to google groups rather than
individuals this way when new members
are added they don't have to be
permitted all of those permissions again
they just need to simply be added to the
group
and finally use predefined roles
whenever possible as opposed to basic
roles which gives us way too much access
and customized roles where you need to
pick and choose from a particular set of
permissions which can be hard to
maintain
let's go over a very short demonstration
for iam
let's head to the console
click on iam and admin which has also
been pinned here
and make sure you're in iem this is the
iam dashboard where you can see a bunch
of different permissions that have
already been assigned
i can add a new role by either editing
here
by adding a new role
or i can go ahead and click on add here
as i want to add it for the same member
which is myself i'm just going to go
ahead and edit here
and add a new role
let's say bigquery viewer
as you can see this has come up which
means now i can access and view the data
from bigquery
now i can go ahead and delete this
and as you can see it's gone
what next a couple of resources have
been added in the description box below
for you to check out for you to get more
details on these concepts
and that brings us to the end of this
video where we went over creating a new
google cloud account did an overview of
the resource hierarchy
we learned how to create an organization
a folder and a project we did an entire
run through of the google cloud console
we understood in brief what iem is and
wrapped it up with a quick demo for iem
in the next episode you'll learn about
serverless application deployment and be
introduced to app engine cloud run and
cloud functions there'll be a section
where we deep dive into cloud run and
look at performance and cost
optimization
we'll also run you through a sample
e-commerce application architecture so
you know what a general architecture
looks like and wrap it up with a
customer success story as to how it's
actually benefited a google cloud
customer
stay tuned for the exciting content that
we have for you don't forget to like and
subscribe to our youtube channel click
on the bell icon to get notified every
time a video has been posted and we will
see you very very soon in our next video
[Music]
you